قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
انه ناقش مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه رد حماس
على المقترحات وان هناك مساحه للتوصل الى
اتفاق واضاف بلينكن في مؤتمر صحفي ان رد
حماس فيه مساحه تساعد على الوصول الى
اتفاق مشيرا الى ان هناك قرارات صعبه يجب
ان تتخذ من جميع الاطراف للمضي قدما واكد
انه يعمل على جمع الافكار والمقترحات من
الاطراف المعنيه لوضعها ضمن خطه واضحه
مشددا على ان المحادثات
ستستمر اتيحت لنا الفرصه اليوم لنناقش مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الرد الذي ارسلته
حماس الليله الماضيه على الاقتراح الذي
قدمته الولايات المتحده وقطر ومصر لاعاده
الرهاءن الى وطنهم وتمديد الهدنه
الانسانيه ما اخبركم به عن المناقشات هو
انه على بالرغم من وجود نقاط غير مشجعه
بشكل واضح في رد فعل حماس الا ان الرد
يوجد مساحه للتوصل الى اتفاق وسنعمل على
ذلك بشكل متواصل حتى نصل الى
هناك